شاهدته والسومريين
يعتقدون أنهم كانوا يصلون هكذا أيضًا في
السابق ثم قلت هذا على الأرجح من أين
جاء هذا وهذا وهذا
وعلى ركبتيك وقلت واو هذا
كان الإسلام قبل
آلاف السنين
[موسيقى]
صندوق أدوات الحياة والانضباط ،
لا أهتم بمدى روعتك ، لا
يهمني مقدار المال الذي لديك إذا كان لديك
نظام في أي شخص ،
فأنت لا تفعله أبدًا ، فأنت بحاجة إلى الانضباط للبقاء على
قيد الحياة في هذا العالم ، فأنت بحاجة إلى أن تكون
قادرًا على فعل ما تريد  تكره أن تفعل ذلك
وتفعله كما تحب ، وهذا أمر
مستحيل تقريبًا بالنسبة لمعظم الناس
، ويتذكرون أنه من الجيد دائمًا
إلقاء اللكمة حيث يمكنك ضربه ، فهو
لا يستطيع ضربك ، وهذا
هو ما يدور حوله علم الملاكمة
[الموسيقى  ]
[موسيقى]
طالما أنها تمنحنا الفهم ،
ثم الأمر متروك لنا للاختيار ،
هل سنختار الفهم
أم سنختار الجانب المظلم لأن
حبنا لا يحتاج إلينا ،
فنحن نحتاج إليه
[موسيقى]
ما يتذكره الناس عن مايك تايسون 50
عامًا  من الآن 50 عامًا ،
لا أعرف أكثر
آلة قتال شرسة تدميراً صنعها الله على الإطلاق
[موسيقى]
إنها تدور حول حياة الحب ،
ربما عندما تعتقد أنك تربح
شخصًا ما حصل على مليار دولار لا يمكنك
إنفاقه عندما '  إن
الحياة الميتة تدور حول الخسارة تمامًا ، نعم لا أحد
يفوز
بك